Now that we've covered the theories and
principles with how to handle animations within the engine,
we're going to hop right into Unreal and begin animating.
Now that we're back here in the editor,
let's take a look at where to
find what we're going to be working with today.
We've already been inside the animation folder,
but now we're going to go into the mesh.
Let's go ahead and double-click in that.
Then inside, you're going to see
a couple other types of meshes.
You have your skeleton and a skeletal mesh.
Go ahead and double-click on the skeleton.
Here on the left, you're going to see the skeleton tree
set up in a hierarchy, as you can see,
every bone that is associated with this.
Now, you can select a bone here in this editor.
Now, you will notice you won't be able to do it in here.
So you want to select over here,
we'll see our root bone,
and there's a really cool little shortcut that we can
do to display and use a button.
So I'm going to come over here to Character,
down to Bones.
Now, see any one of these selections,
if you hit Shift,
left mouse button, you're going to create a button.
So I'm going to go ahead and do that for a couple others.
I'm going to do that for selected only,
and let's do another one for none.
So now we have all these buttons, we can select it,
makes it a lot easier in order to show our bones.
Now that we have our skeleton all set and ready to go,
before we add a socket,
we need to understand what a socket is.
So a socket is basically a point that is attached to a bone.
What does this mean?
This means it gives us the ability to attach something
somewhere on our skeleton, say like a razor gun,
or a backpack, or even a hat.
Whatever you decide to do,
what this allows you to do is to swap out said meshes.
So you could change your different types of guns,
different hats, different backpacks.
And this is what this is going to allow us to do.
So let's go ahead and hop back into the engine
and do that.
Here we see our skeletal mesh again,
and we want to attach a socket.
So where do we want to do that?
Well, I'm going to attach a backpack.
So I'm going to select some here along the spine.
I'm going to select the third spine zero three,
and then I'm going to come over here
to the skeleton tree, and I'm going to right click.
I'm going to look for this add socket option.
All right.
Now you'll notice it names it as spine zero three socket.
So for referencing later and let's say blueprints,
or even just for general cleanup,
let's go ahead and rename this to backpack.
And you can put SOC or SOC, whatever you want to do.
I'm just do SOC.
All right.
Now you'll notice that there's nothing there.
So what do we have to do is we have to add
a preview mesh.
So let's go ahead and right click on there.
And you're going to notice this option here
is add preview.
So let's do a search for a backpack
and we'll see the skeletal mesh of the backpack.
So let's go ahead and click that.
And you'll see, ta-da, it's on there,
but it looks kind of weird, right?
Well, we have to rotate it in location.
So this is what we're going to do.
So we're going to kind of move it into place.
I'm going to rotate that about 90 degrees,
about to there and rotate it here, 90 degrees.
That looks good.
And I'm going to move it back to the back
to where I like it.
See, this is wherever you want to place it.
So let me make sure it gets pretty close.
That looks pretty good.
All right.
So now our mesh is in place.
Now you'll notice we didn't rotate it
from the preview socket, but rather the socket itself.
So we didn't do it on the mesh, but on the socket.
Now, this is important to note.
If you attach different size objects,
if you scale it or rotate it,
it's going to take on these transforms
that we just applied.
So just be aware of that when you're building
or adding additional sockets that you want to make sure
that they're rotated in the same direction.
Otherwise you're going to have flipped backpacks
sideways rotated inside the character.
And that's not what you're going to want to do.
So that's pretty much it.
So come up here and hit save.
And a good habit to get to is to save all,
which is control shift S.
I like to do that because you never know.
And then you're done.
So we're going to be able to use this in our animation.
So that's the next thing.
Let's get started on an animation.